non
bonsoir le chiffre 13 pour signer un
exploit 13h13 vendredi 13 pascal barrier
à retrouver la lumière du jour
emmuré volontaire dans une grotte des
cévennes pendant cent treize jours il
avait perdu toute notion du temps il est
sorti de ses 40 kilomètres de galeries
souterraines et obscur pressé de revivre
nous le retrouverons en direct dans un
instant le temps de revoir son exploit
en images dominique dumas défi
superstition tout simplement hasard
pascal bary a choisi 1,13 pour revenir à
la lumière isolés pendant cent treize
jours dans cette grotte de la cocalière
sans montre ni radio
il a aussi co embrasser corinne sa femme
qu'il n'avait pas vu depuis le 22
novembre dernier
je suis vraiment pas trop émue et puis
bon je suis heureux même si ça soit pas
bon je suis très heureux de ces jours
puisque j'ai beaucoup de hauts de moi
mais je pense avoir vécu tout ce qu'un
jeune peut ressentir des moments très
divers de joie de peine est capable
parce qu'elle ne sait pas vraiment
ennuyé au programme lectures exercices
physiques footing au total 1000 km dans
les galeries
il a quand même perdu la notion du temps
et à durée qui libre et son biorythme
depuis le début du mois il devra
d'ailleurs subir des tests à montpellier
relatifs aux mécanismes du sommeil
pascal bach y avait déjà réaliser
d'autres exploits comme la traversée des
gorges du verdon à moutons mais sur un
câble à 400 mètres de hauteur pascal
fait désormais partie de ces humains
ayant vécu hors du temps pascal barrier
et bonsoir merci d'être avec nous est-ce
que vous vous sentez bien ce soir
moi ça va je suis un peu fatigué
l'émotion est un peu parti la lumière
vous agresse encore tellement oui c'est
un peu pour m'habituer de la lumière et
c'est parce que je les suis aussi d
expérience au niveau des yeux vous allez
rentrer à l'hôpital ce soir
oui bah pour faire certains tests dont
je ne prenais pas encore les exactement
là
la teneur oui c'est ça sert que le bon
je suis sorti on m'a dit ce soit l
hôpital on l'avait un peu dit avant mai
je ne sais rien du tout je sais que
c'est simplement service du professeur
be your qui va me faire quelques études
au niveau devant ce mail de mon cycle
biologique au niveau des yeux aussi mais
tout ce que je sais ça veut dire que
vous avez tenté l'exploit pour l'exploit
est pas l'exploit pour ses conséquences
scientifique
oui dès le départ j'ai mis le côté
scientifique de côté et j'ai voulu vivre
une expérience humaine sert me retrouver
tout seul dans une grotte au style pour
pouvoir
disons me tester physiquement et
psychologiquement
en sortant vous a entendu tout à l'heure
vous avez parlé de moments difficiles de
déprime est ce que vous avez eu des
cauchemars des hallucinations
j'ai eu une seule destination j'ai
entendu un chien abandonné
c'est un aboiement j'ai pas beaucoup
fait de cauchemar j'ai eu c'est vrai
quelques périodes de cafard de mode
période noire
mais dans l'ensemble tout s'est bien
passé je suis très heureuse fort alors
vous avez parlé donc de déprimer on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de faire le rapport
avec l'expérience qu'ils avaient vécu
véronique le guen c'était aussi 110
jours dans une grotte
quelques semaines plus tard elle s'est
suicidée vous avez vraiment le moral
oui je pense que suite à une telle
expérience on peut avoir une envie de
vivre
je dirais essayer de le rattraper le
même temps perdu bon j'ai pu faire le
point voir ce qu'ils avaient un peu
clochers dans la vie et bon jeu
maintenant aujourd'hui à 7 7 minutes
dont j'ai envie de vivre à cent à
l'heure et de faire beaucoup de choses
autant de choses que j'ai fait une
dernière question très rapidement vous
êtes sorti un vendredi très retrait à
13h13 vous êtes superstitieux non ce
totalement loser merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
coup d'éclat à d'act up ce matin un
symposium sur la sécurité
transfusionnelle à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière à paris
cible de cette association de lutte
contre le sida le docteur habib sy
directeur adjoint du centre national de
transfusion sanguine dans les années 85
pour les militants d'act up
il est impliqué dans la sphère des
transfusés contaminé par le virus du
sida
ils le lui ont vivement fait savoir
robert papin victor arich ce n'est que
du colorant rouge mais cela produit son
effet le docteur amy lee en a fait la
triste expérience ce matin les trentaine
de militants d'act up a fait irruption
au symposium sur la sécurité
transfusionnelle
il exige son inculpation le docteur
habib sy était directeur adjoint du
centre national de transfusion sanguine
en 1985 pour acteurs
il savait que les produits sanguins
destinés aux hémophiles été contaminés
ils veulent que la justice agisse on
voit qu'il ya une justice à deux
vitesses puisque pour les anabolisants
chez leveaux en inculpant n'incarcère et
dans le problème de la transfusion
sanguine et des produits dérivés pour
les hémophiles
toutes les personnes sont encore en
liberté je crois qu'on est dans une
période où maintenant l'ouverture existe
le dialogue existe la possibilité de
s'expliquer existe je pense qu'il faut
le faire dans le calme
ça ne sert absolument à rien d'avoir ce
genre de manifestation cette femme et la
mère d'un homme aux fils aujourd'hui âgé
de 17 ans est contaminé par le virus du
sida en 1985 comme beaucoup de parents
d'hémophiles l injecter elle même les
produits sanguins à son fils
au mois d'octobre 85
on avait encore des produits contaminés
qui étaient fournies par le service du
docteur habib sy et c'était dramatique
parce qu'on m'a annoncé que mon fils
était séropositif et même après octobre
85 ch avait encore des produits
contaminés mais je le savais pas vous
comprenez ce que c'est pour une mère si
toutes les semaines mois je faisais des
piqûres avec des produits qui contenait
la psd mon fils est malade maintenant
j'estime que cet homme doit être puni
doit être inculpé
fortement choqués par cette action le
docteur avis n'a pas pu s'exprimer
devant les caméras la quasi totalité des
personnes présentes au symposium ont
signé une pétition de soutien en sa
faveur politique dix jours des élections
régionales des cantonales deux candidats
ont mené des campagnes nationales
presque des campagnes pour des
présidentielles jacques chirac et michel
rocard campagne en forme de marathon
pour le président du rpr elle se
terminera à paris la semaine prochaine
et pour la province fin ce week end chez
lui dans le limousin carnet de campagne
michel lemerle
voilà c'est parti en réalité sous
jacques chirac que fille pratiquement la
mi janvier
en deux mois il aura sillonné plus de la
moitié des régions françaises et près du
tiers des départements
contrairement aux dirigeants de gdf qui
ont privilégié la bataille au sein de
leur région
le président du rpr a délibérément
choisi de mener une campagne nationale
il n'y a pas d'élection est essentielle
et d'élections secondaire il y à un seul
combat politique
jacques chirac a répondu avec le même
appétit à des initiatives rpr il ya des
invitations des lumières qui n'ont pas
été insensibles à ce coup de pouce ce
n'est pas un mauvais calcul pour un
présidentiable qui rencontrent ainsi sur
le terrain ce qui le moment venu seront
des électeurs privilégier les primaires
de l'opposition avec ce pilonnage
intensif
faire de ces élections la première salve
avant les législatives de 93,1 faut-il
encore concentrer en priorité le tir sur
les objectifs des médias tous les
arguments inlassablement repris pendant
cette campagne
la mise en garde contre l'abstention
contre l'éparpillement des voix sur les
petites listes et le tir nourri centre
le front national et les socialistes
accusés de favoriser le développement de
l'extrême droite
ce sont des forces qui quand on les
libère risque de faire très mal et qui
sont absolument indigne de l'humanisme
et des valeurs traditionnelles de notre
pays
il faut dit prendre garde et ça c'est la
responsabilité des socialistes ils vont
la jouer les apprentis sorciers des
thèmes qui seront à nouveau développée
dans les prochains jours jacques chirac
joue en quelque sorte que les dernières
rencontres à domicile
dans le limousin puis dans la région
parisienne michel rocard n'est pas
candidat il a pourtant mouiller sa
chemise dans cette campagne pour les
régionales il est allé à la rencontre
des français bien sûr mais aussi des
socialistes et pas seulement des
rocardiens celui qui n'était encore que
candidat virtuel espère ainsi gagner sa
place de présidentiable de la gauche à
part entière daniel sportive mais
attention solidarité vous êtes à pied
solidaires michel rocard veulent être en
toutes circonstances c'est ainsi qu'il a
décidé d'épauler le ps en ces temps
difficiles
n'étant pas de ceux qui quittent le
bateau quand il prend l'eau le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine ne ménage donc
ni son temps ni sa peine pour tenter de
redresser la barre aux régionales
même s'il n'est pas lui même candidat il
y a en ce moment beaucoup de malaise
dans la vie politique partie sur des
malentendus partie sur des espérances
excessive mais je pense que dieu a pas
de raison qu'on en sorte un message qui
s'adresse au delà des socialistes à tous
les français car cette campagne sert
aussi pour le candidat virtuel du ps de
galop d'essai pour les présidentielles
mais si michel rocard entend redonner le
moral aux français parce qu'en france
estime-t-il
ça ne va pas si mal ils s'interdisent de
leur promettre la lune
je me suis fait une certaine célébrité
autrefois comme briseur de rêves on
aurait pu on a peur je me bats au moins
contre les faux rebelle et contre les
prétentions des baguettes magiques qui
vont là où des alternants vérité crue et
message d'espoir michel rocard tente
donc aujourd'hui de restaurer son image
d' adepte du parler vrai une parole qui
fit sa popularité mais que son passage à
matignon mi-temps sur digne avec la
parole retrouvée
michel rocard s'offre donc à l'occasion
de cette campagne une véritable cure de
jouvence de ne rien dire ou de ne rien
promettre qu'on ne puisse faire est de
ne pas bien faire qu'on n'ose pas dire
c'est aux actes
que j'entends qu'on soit jugée -
notamment le message est donc lancé mais
michel rocard devra encore attendre les
présidentielles pour en mesurer les
effets si le parti socialiste lui en
laisse l'opportunité mais déficit
budgétaire pour 91 s'est finalement
élevé à presque 132 milliards de france
51 milliards de plus que prévu un
dérapage de 63% et transiter en douane
français qui ont bloqués 48 heures
durant la frontière franco-espagnole
reprennent le travail les bouchons poids
lourds vont de se résorber pause dans le
conflit le gouvernement a promis de leur
envoyer un émissaire dès la semaine
prochaine les transitaires côté français
comme côté espagnol sont très inquiets
sur leur avenir avec l'ouverture des
frontières européennes en 93 bataille
pour la paix dans le haut karabagh et
pour la première fois l'onu s'engage
dans les républiques de la défunte union
soviétique
boutros ghali envoie un nouvel émissaire
cyrus vance l'homme qui a négocié
l'envoi de casques bleus en yougoslavie
la france propose à ses partenaires de
la csc heure et demie à helsinki la
convocation d'une conférence pour un
cessez le feu et la turquie très active
depuis l'extension des combats annoncé
ce matin une trêve un cessez le feu
provisoire
jean françois grégoire cet homme et
suleyman demirel le premier ministre
d'york il a annoncé ce matin qu'un
cessez le feu temporaire avait été
établi au nagorny karabach entre armée
liens et la sérigraphie suleyman demirel
vieux lion de la vie politique turque
sait mieux que quiconque combien son
pays'' gros dans la crise du caucase
malgré la pression de l'opposition qui
souhaite l'envoi de troupes turques pour
aider les azéri le gouvernement de mir
elle joue à fond la carte de la solution
négociée pour renouer avec l'arménie
tout en ménageant l'azerbaïdjan amis
ankara est aussi soucieux de soigner son
image face à l'occident qu'il observe
washington moscou paris et en demandé
aux turcs de faire ce qu'il pouvait pour
aider à trouver une solution négociée
une extension du conflit serait donc
dramatique pour la turquie
sur le terrain les adversaires sont
prêtes à poursuivre les combats
habité par la haine de l'autre bien loin
de se soucier pour l'instant des
initiatives
le fait qu'elle soit turc européenne
vient des nations unies autre point de
tension dans l'ancienne union soviétique
le contentieux entre l'ukraine et la
russie l'ukraine qui décide de ne plus
transférer vers la russie ses armes
nucléaires tactiques question de
conscience ou chantage à une semaine du
sommet de la série consacrée aux
questions militaires
jean paul gérard l'hémicycle ukrainien
vont s'arrêter sur la route de moscou
résultat une nouvelle panne de la coi en
annonçant une suspension temporaire du
transfert de ces armes nucléaires
tactiques pour la russie le président
ukrainien leonid kravtchouk a remise en
cause l'un des rares accords conclus par
la nouvelle communauté d'états lors de
sa création
les quatre républiques détentrice
d'armes nucléaires s'était engagé à
transférer en russie
l'ensemble des missiles du kazakhstan de
biélorussie et d'ukraine pour qu'elle
soit détruite
à terme la russie devait rester la seule
république à conserver une force de
frappe
seulement leonid kravtchouk n'a plus
confiance selon lui la confusion et
l'instabilité politique qui règne en
russie peuvent faire craindre que ces
armements ne soit pas effectivement
détruits ou qu'ils ne tombent entre de
mauvaises mains
argument évidemment recevable mais il
s'agit sans doute aussi pour le leader
et craignant de réfuter encore une fois
tout leadership russe dans la nouvelle
communauté à nouveau défi à boris
eltsine est probablement un atout une
monnaie d échange que leonid kravtchouk
entend garder à la proche du prochain
sommet de la coi la semaine prochaine à
kiev allait signer kravtchouk s'y
affronteront sur d'autres dossiers
épineux en particulier sur le sort de la
flotte de la mer noire
pas de négociation possible le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu n'a pas cédé à la
plaidoirie de l'irakien tarek aziz
l'application intégrale immédiate des
résolutions de l'onu ou rien et membre
du conseil de sécurité ont refusé un
allègement progressif de l'embargo ils
sont prêts à redonner encore une chance
à bagdad
il demande des actes concrets
l'élimination d'armes de destruction
massive
retour en france avec le procès des
tueurs à la 205 rouge un procès qui
tourne court
report toute la semaine l'audience avait
été émaillée d'incidents
un des trois accusés avaient
régulièrement refusé de comparaître et
cet après midi les deux gitans présents
ont récusé leurs défenseurs sous
prétexte de parodie de justice albert
est pas mon
la salle se vide le procès des tueurs
présumés à la 205 rouge vient de faire
long feu ce matin seuls didier rossi et
jean winterstein ont accepté de
comparaître
michel suite lui ne veut rien savoir et
reste dans sa cellule
à 16 heures le président pouvait
constater l'impossibilité de poursuivre
les débats
d'autant que winterstein héros s'ils
s'en vont à leur tour et récuse leurs
défenseurs ces hommes faits gitans
soupçonnés de vol de viol et de meurtre
clame depuis le début leur innocence et
leurs avocats estiment que trop de
pistes ont été négligés dans une
instruction délibérément orientées nous
ne voulons pas qu'il y ait une justice à
deux vitesses une pour les gitans et
l'autre pour les gaulois
parce que cette visite justice à deux
vitesses les dons sont en scandale est
dans son principe mais là encore plus
scandaleuse parce que le s'appuierait
sur des considérations raciales
désappointé les victimes des noces cette
manoeuvre qu'elle considère comme étant
destiné à gagner du temps et trois ans
quelque chose d'immense avait trois ans
quand même tout le monde en bateau et
qu'il y avait aujourd'hui l'image de la
justice tels que tout un chacun peut
l'apercevoir même si les droits de la
défense doivent être respectés
absolument
je prends cette image elle est quand
même un peu entachée aux cerises ce que
déplorer les accusés et leurs familles
ont finalement plus ce qu'ils
recherchaient une deuxième chance le
procès est reporté à 8 c sur ultérieure
et l'on repartira de zéro
la police va bientôt dire adieu à ses
dossiers manuel grâce à un système
informatique est centralisé de
reconnaissance des empreintes digitales
un système français tellement efficace
que les allemands dont la police est
l'une des meilleures du monde ont déjà
adopté une forme de collaboration
européenne avant l'heure béatrice niveau
alors au pelletier ces fameuses fiches
signalétiques iront tel à la poubelle
non elles sont désormais au musée elle
concerne des bandits célèbre cappone
dealing heures ou clyde barrow celui de
bonnie parker ils ont sévi à une époque
où l'informatique ne régnait pas encore
ce système a permis l'année dernière
d'identifier 110 malfaiteurs ou de
détecter 1300 emprunt d'identité
maintenant lors d'un homicide
à moins de retracer prélever envoyé ici
comparé analyser la machine propose une
quinzaine de solutions le spécialiste de
l'identité judiciaire choisie efficacité
totale et gain de temps pour une
comparaison avant treize jours à deux
mois et demi aujourd'hui deux minutes à
un quart d'heure
l'appareillage coûteux est utile au
quotidien comme sur de grandes affaires
attentats enlèvements ou série de
meurtres
paulin avait été arrêté auparavant à
toulouse où ces traces papillaires avait
également été engrangés enregistrées
dans un fichier local les à l'époque
entre le fichier est à toulouse et au
fichier qui était à paris on pouvait pas
de fer comparée de comparaison qu'est ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire interroger les
dizaines de fichiers des cas d'accident
air qui avait en france c'était un
travail très fastidieux très long et
qu'il n'était pas fait systématiquement
230000 fils informatisé la police
française espère arriver à 3 millions ce
système sera bientôt décentralisée un
système qui a déjà été choisi par
l'ecosse le pays basque aujourd'hui
l'allemagne
c'est un contrat d'un montant élevé pour
nous et d'autre part et représente une
référence tout à fait intéressante pour
nous parce que la police allemande est
réputée parmi toutes les polices du
monde comme étant une des plus
performantes avec un tel système le
grand sherlock holmes aurait-il encore
une raison d'être
jean-pierre verra ce policier soupçonné
d'avoir transmis une liste d'opposants
libanais à l'ambassade du liban inculpé
de vol recel et violation du secret
professionnel inculpation tardive selon
son avocat les faits remontent à octobre
91 avec une manifestation d'opposants au
président libanais et arabes où un
pompier volontaire inculpé il est accusé
d'avoir allumé un contre-feu il a
toujours nié les faits remontent à l'été
90 aqaba sont dans le var prise entre
ceux des contre-feux quatre personnes
étaient mortes ce jour là mais cette
inculpation jette le trouble chez les
pompiers volontaires du var didier
aurillac t1 juin 90 à une demi-heure
d'intervalle deux incendies éclatent sur
la commune de cabasson dans le var
bloqué entre les deux feux prise au
piège quatre pompiers périssent brûlé
selon l' enquête de la police un
lieutenant roland terre est à l'origine
de ce drame
il aurait été vu par des témoins sur les
lieux d'où serait parti le deuxième
foyer
selon le juge d'instruction qui vient
donc de l'inculpé le lieutenant venait
d'allumer un contre-feu une accusation
rejetée par les pompiers du var le
débriefing fait on veut bien qu'il n'ya
jamais eu de contre-feu allumé par les
sapeurs pompiers
ce n'est pas une pratique qui se fait
dans notre département
il s'agit pour nous d'une sorte de feu
qui se trouvait au plus bas c'est 100 m
à ce moment
des arguments qui n'ont pas convaincu le
juge celui ci veut entendre les
responsables des sapeurs pompiers pour
savoir si en allumant un éventuel
contre-feu le lieutenant n'aurait pas
simplement obéi à ses supérieurs
un soupçon très mal acceptée par les
pompiers du var qui veulent à présent
que la vérité éclate au plus vite et du
chesnay isabelle et paul champions du
monde de danse sur glace et médaille
d'argent seulement vous vous en souvenez
aux jeux olympiques et du chesnay
raccroche les patins
ils mettent un terme à leur carrière
amateur ils n'iront même pas à la fin du
mois aux championnats du monde en
californie ils vont passer dans les
rangs aux professionnels didier chaumont
isabelle et paul duchesnay ont livré
leur dernier combat amateur sur la
patinoire d'albertville le but de toute
la carrière des du chênet et les jeux
olympiques où ils ont dû se contenter de
la médaille d'argent après cinq ans de
travail intense et de lutte
aujourd'hui il passe chez les
professionnels il aura certainement
quelques tournées qui vont se faire en
tant que professionnel avec une troupe
plus elle sera évidemment très grave
probablement enseigner quelque part mais
une école très spécial on a déjà
quelques idées quelques plats en tête
qu'on a mis en route faut attendre fois
temps de voir combien de temps on va
tenir le professionnalisme avant de se
lancer dans l'enseignement paul et
isabelle garde jalousement leur secret
est une chose est sûre ils ne
participeront pas à la fin du moins au
championnat du monde en californie
pour la fédération c'est toujours
dommage de ne pas avoir ses meilleurs
coups n'est engagée dans la compétition
cela dit nous avons deux autres couples
qui ont fait 8e et 9e aux jeux
olympiques donc je dirais que pour eux
c'est maintenant à eux de prendre le
destin de la france en main et je crois
qu'ils sont tout à fait armé pour ça les
du chéné ont fait leurs adieux à cet
univers des compétitions officielles
eux qui ont révolutionné la danse sur
glace ils avaient choisi l'audace plutôt
que le conformisme
le couple français da désormais rompre
avec la tradition pour se donner
entièrement à leur fantaisie et leur
créativité chez les amateurs ils auront
malgré tout connu leur heure de gloire
avec un titre de champion du monde l'an
dernier à munich
cyclisme et la 6e étape du paris nice
victoire d'étape au suisse tommy reining
heures mais jean-françois bernard
endosse le maillot blanc de leader
jean claude valentin breaux départ ce
matin de marseille tout le monde
s'attendait à ce que cette étape soit
décisive et dumb les cinq hommes
attaquent quevedo robette yates
l'italien sanguy alta et le français
francis moreau ils compteront six
minutes 35 d'avancé sur un peloton dans
lequel miguel indurain et jean-françois
bernard font le forcing avec leurs
coéquipiers de l'équipe bannissent tôt
les échappés seront repris à 40
kilomètres de l'arrivée
reste le faron à gravir un gros morceau
qui peut creuser les écarts
le premier attaqué pour ce vendredi 13
est le numéro 13
jean françois bernard avec roaming
guerre le suisse et les espagnols
montoya et une du renne la bagarre a été
incessantes sur les 5 kilomètres de
montée dans les derniers 200 mètres
roaming guère réussi à prendre quelques
secondes à jean-françois bernard qui va
arriver
épuisé mais qui prend tout de même le
maillot de leader à son coéquipier
miguel indurain
même s'il est toujours plus favorable
d'aborder le col d'eze avec 20 secondes
d'avancé avec 20 de retard et je crois
que pour l'instant si ça se passe comme
ça jusque dimanche après midi
situation qui me seront à ses parents
demain 7e étape entre toulon et
mandelieu coupe de l'america une défaite
hier soir pour ville de paris battue par
les italiens di mauro di venezia qui ont
franchi la ligne d'arrivée avec plus de
trois minutes d'avancé une régate par
petit temps
il reste une chance à l'équipage de marc
pajot pour se qualifier pour les demi
finales
vaincre dimanche espagne à 92 tout de
suite cela météo complète de michel
touré puis un livre un jour suivi de la
classe et de thalassa vous retrouverez
marque hautement pour soir 3 à 22h45 et
erika chars pour les éditions du
week-end lundi que la marée élise lucet
passé un très beau week-end parfois
le tout
m